welcome to the man of recaps this is the
witcher season two we start off in the
aftermath of the huge battle where the
wizards fought off the nilfgaard
invasion in the end yennefer saved the
day by unleashing a huge blast of fire
magic but now yennefer's missing
presumed dead then our witcher shows up
it's geralt of rivia who's hanging out
with siri princess cirilla his newfound
adopted daughter child of destiny he and
jennifer have been in a 100-year
on-again off-again relationship and he's
pretty sad to hear she's dead but
jennifer's alive she was taken captive
by the retreating nilfgaard forces more
on her later so geralt's new main goal
in life is to protect siri his child of
destiny he's got kind of a grumpy dad
thing going well she's a rambunctious
teenager so very quickly these two are
bonded for their first stop they visit
geralt's old friend pumbaa from the lion
king but he's hiding his new girlfriend
from geralt because she is oh nope nope
nope actually though she's kind of a
friendly monster these two have a good
thing going on where she needs to drink
blood and he's immortal so it's
consensual who am i to judge but she
also did eat the entire nearby village
so geralt judges he busts in there does
what he does best and monster slays so
their next stop hidden high up in the
mountains the witcher home base
caramorin the few witchers that are left
all hang out here for winter break and
it's got kind of a fun frat house vibe
their house daddy is the one old witcher
vesemir one of the witchers just killed
a tree monster and wouldn't you know it
he got infected turned into a tree
monster himself now geralt's gotta kill
him and carol realizes he might not
always be there to protect her the best
way to keep siri safe is to teach her
how to fight now over to yennefer who's
being held captive by fringilla who
remembers the sorceress working for
nilfgaard but pretty soon they're
ambushed and captured by the elves
remember elves in this world are
horribly discriminated against and being
genocided by humans their leader right
now is this elf sorceress francesca
jennifer tries to play the hey i'm a
quarter elf on my grandmother's side
card but they're like yo you ain't got
pointy ears you don't know our struggle
but right now she needs their help to
find the secret hidden forest with a
mysterious hut in it and if you say the
magic words turn your front to me hot oh
the hut turns around inside they'll see
who they want to see the elf seas the
elf goddess frangilluses the god emperor
of nilfgaard the white flame but
jennifer realizes it's definitely some
super sketchy ancient witch demon she
offers them each what they most desire
which for yennefer is to get her magic
back yes after the big fireball she's
lost her connection but jennifer turns
her down for now like yo this is clearly
a trap the other two though they accept
so they travel to sintra yes siri's old
kingdom that nilfgaard captured at the
beginning of season one nilfgaard takes
in the elven refugees in exchange for
joining their army to fight against
their common enemy the northern kingdoms
the elf queen gets what she wants the
first elven baby in like a thousand
years and fragile gets what she wants
rising higher in the nilfgaard hierarchy
jennifer goes back to the mage castle
eratusa like sup ball i'm alive she's
got good friends here like her fellow
sorceresses and her mama bear tisea but
she's kind of in trouble because fire
magic is very much against the rules and
this old douchebag straga bore thinks
she's an ilf-guard spy now the mages did
capture kahir the black knight of
nilfgaard and to prove she's not a spy
they're gonna make jennifer execute him
but jennifer's like hey i saved all your
butts if you don't trust me screw you
i'm out of here meanwhile siri is doing
great in her training she does the
witcher obstacle course and oh wipeout
but now it's time to deal with siri's
unexplained magical powers where she has
like visions of the future they follow
the vision to find the tree monster but
oh it's instantly killed by this other
gross monster geralt the monster expert
has never seen anything like this but
that doesn't stop him from slaying it
now remember at the very beginning of
season one when siri screamed and
toppled over that ancient monolith
geralt has a theory that these new types
of monsters are somehow coming from it
so he goes to the resident monolith
expert istrid who was jennifer's college
boyfriend so it's time we learn about
the history of this world specifically
the conjunction of the spheres a long
long time ago a bunch of worlds all
crashed together and merged into this
one elves and humans were from different
worlds but now on the same one along
with unfortunately monsters but the new
theory is maybe the worlds didn't stay
merged the other worlds are still out
there and the monoliths connect them
that's where the new monsters are coming
from and somehow siri is the key so
geralt brings in his old sorceress
friend tris marigold to check out siri's
visions first they discover that siri
has elder blood which could be used to
make a new witcher formula and siri
wants to be a witcher just like her papa
g but geralt's like yo no kid it's too
dangerous so to figure out her powers
tris takes siri into a magic nap to her
past here we meet the human version of
siri's father remember in season one we
only met him as the cursed sonic the
hedgehog her parents were concerned she
fulfilled some prophecy that's why they
had to run away and going even further
back her great great greater grandmother
was an elf who fell in love with a human
and prophesied one of their descendants
would bring about the end of days with
the horsemen of the apocalypse so watch
out for that so geralt figures that's
their cue to leave but on the way they
find a new monster that oh no attacks
the horse oh not roach geralt's real mad
now he chugs a monster energy drink that
makes his eyes go all black and how
slays this monster don't mess with a
man's horse meanwhile jennifer and kahir
are on the run and they hear of a bard
who can smuggle him out of town yes it's
yaskir but remember the last time he and
geralt met geralt was in a real bad mood
and told him he didn't want to be
friends anymore so yesker's new song
this season is burn butcher burn an
intense emotional ballad about a best
friend breakup not quite as catchy as
tossing your witcher though so he and
jennifer aren't exactly friends but he
hooks her up with a trip out of town but
just then he's kidnapped yes there's
some other random woman who hired this
criminal fire mage to track down siri
who was last seen with geralt who was
last seen with yaskir so jennifer comes
to save him but without her magic she's
got to improvise oh alcohol fire to the
face so they're out of the fire but into
the frying pan when they're immediately
captured by city guards and jennifer is
like fine i give up turn your front to
me hot hot so creepy huttwitch tells her
how to get her magic back she's gotta
find this girl's siri and bring her to a
monolith so gareth brings siri to a safe
happy temple where she can learn to
control some of her magic but now
jennifer is there looking for siri and
is surprised to find geralt oh yen
you're alive yeah these two reunited so
it's quite a curveball that the random
girl she's looking for happens to be
geralt's child of destiny but just then
fire guys back with a whole gang of
ruffians and so it's finally time for a
napkin fight yes so so sweet it's in
that awesome style from the very first
episode of season one and if netflix
were to hire me as a consultant my
advice would be put one of these sweet
fights in every single episode the fire
guy is after series so jennifer teaches
her how to use her magic to open a
portal but geralt chases this guy off
like hey i won the fight you don't have
to escape but jennifer's like sorry boo
i gotta do what's best for me and steal
siri away so gareth goes for some bro
time with yaskir apologizes for being
such a dick and geralt knows this
huttwitch is the deathless mother an
ancient demon the witchers imprisoned a
thousand years ago so jennifer is
leading siri into a trap in hopes to get
her magic back but along the way she
starts to teach siri more magic and
starts to really like this kid so when
they get to the monolith the other
changes her mind hey girl i'm sorry i
was drinking you just then geralt
catches up to him and is pretty mad at
jennifer she's like yeah i'm sorry this
was my bad she warps them back to the
hot mother to find she's already escaped
yes over in sintra things were going
good for these two eventually kahir
shows up and has a nice shave and
there's a lot going on here i'm gonna
try to streamline quickly there's the
elf kid serie met in season one who's
being forced to spy by this owl who's
actually a woman who's working for the
buff old bald wizard who's working for
some king that's doing some scheming in
fact all those are just scheming that's
what they do the current council leaders
are the old guys dragoborn and artorius
but vilgefortz the hero of the battle is
challenging their seat with his running
mate mama bear tessella in fact these
two are dating and they win the election
they're the new leaders but when tris
tells tasea that siri might start the
apocalypse vilgefortz gets mad she
didn't tell him and shows his true
colors yes remember in season one after
the battle vilgefortz killed one of his
fellow wizards so who knows what he's up
to anyway back in cintra many of the
nilfgaard generals don't like frangilla
or the elves so francilla poisons them
with the paralyzed wine and oh takes
them all out she keeps kahira alive
though like hey man you're cool let's be
friends meanwhile the elves have their
first elven baby in a long long time but
it makes them want to stop fighting for
nilfgaard but then the baby's
assassinated and the elves assume it was
the northern kingdom so they go on a
rampage she uses her magic to murder all
the human babies passover style so the
hot mother feeds on suffering and now
she's had enough she breaks free and
possesses siri geralt goes full molly
weasley not my daughter you but the hutt
mother uses siri's scream power to break
apart the witcher's tree which oh has a
monolith inside it and she knows how to
control siri's power to turn it into a
portal to summon monsters from another
dimension so all the witchers are
fighting velociraptors geralt's got the
big one outside and boom smotes its ruin
upon the mountainside in the end
jennifer is willing to sacrifice herself
draws the hot mother out of siri into
her but now siri's like hey i think i
know how to banish her and whoa opens
portal plam the three of them teleported
to mars and now the hot mother bails
because this is her home planet and
she's able to get her original body back
and she's one of the horsemen of the
apocalypse the wild hunt they're like
hey siri you're one of us time to join
the wild hunt but siri for now pisses
them out of there what is the wild hunt
geralt seems to know but doesn't tell us
yet and somehow as part of this
adventure jennifer gets her magic back
alright and so papa g little siri and
mama yanian make a happy little found
family ready to protect siri from
whoever's haunting her and there are a
lot of people hunting her the northern
human kingdoms want her dead for
political reasons because she's the
princess of sintra and to say is
normally a good guy but is helping them
probably to stop the apocalypse but now
the elves learn about siri and want to
use her to start the apocalypse to wipe
out humanity then there's burnt face
firemage working for a mysterious boss
by the way they stole that one witcher
making juice and the girl he's working
with tried to snort it which is not how
you use it and no now she's uglier than
him and of course there's nilfgaard who
was hunting siri before it was cool and
now coming to sintra is the god emperor
himself emir the white flame now
franjilla really was friends with the
elf queen and would never have killed
her baby but she decides to take credit
for it to show that she's a good leader
who can make the hard choices but the
emperor is like i know you lying cause
i'm the one that killed the elf baby and
turns out the white flame is series
father yes sonic the hedgehog is now the
main villain what's his real motivations
for hunting his daughter siri find out
in the witcher season 3.
if you liked this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you loved
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member